foreign
if you wanted to um you know go out
sometime you want to get a coffee now
yes now
I'll just hang on when I wake up well I
know I'm gonna be her name is Sadie
I mean I know this sounds crazy I think
she might be the one
who goes along with you she really is
great you'll see
any word
she goes to them I bet she hasn't even
seen your text she does travel a lot for
work go to her I'm going to London
It's a grand romantic gesture that is
amazing Mike five thousand miles to
surprise a girl who you've only met once
especially if she's the one who ghosted
you
no no she didn't ghost me she just
doesn't have an international calling
plan all right
[Music]
where am I
oh God you you have the wrong guy I'm a
former wait wait oh
[Music]
can you walk goal
CIA
I'm so confused they kept asking me
about the tax man they asked you about
the attacks man they think I am
attachment
you're the tax man oh my God oh my God
you got me kidnapped and tortured all
after one day
I Saw The Rock
you're the one who flew to London
it was a romantic gesture
get every bounty hunt on the cockpit I
want her life
this is bigger than you and me
didn't never occur to you that he could
be a foreign asset trying to compromise
your mission
now
who the hell are you
I'm the boyfriend
[Music]
do you trust me is that a joke